gotta jump into tights another show that  I'm a big fan I've seen all the episodes  where are you guys at in terms of did  you start filming season three or  everything I shut down or no no writers  room Greg Walker is running the writers  room in season three and he you know  everything is all you know I mean  stories have been developed but  everything is a little bit slowed down  obviously but nope season 3 EO is  planning to go in front of the cameras  as soon as possible do you know many  episodes it's gonna be thirteen a season  two introduced Batman and had a blast  with it is there talk of having Batman  come back or any other DC characters  joint chip I am NOT gonna tell you that  only you can I can't help myself for at  least digging a look absolutely you know  look is there anything that you can  tease for season three for fans  series  not just that it will be filming at some  point when things get that yes and we're  excited by it I will leave it there